like if i was to get a girl friend and
i'm like look this is the one for me and
i'm proposed her
guys always look at the factors of like
now i can guarantee you
i want to say 7 out of 10 girls don't
know how to cook don't know how to clean
yeah don't know how to take care of the
household because all they know is like
yeah but then at the same time though
just to give brace to them have they
been taught that
exactly but that's the worst part they
haven't that's all i think sometimes and
this is probably one of my few qualms i
have with kevin samuels whereby he goes
who taught you that
but i think they came from broken homes
so of course they're not going to be
told how to do that also i don't know a
single girl my age that has a cookbook i
mean i'm sorry i'm so tired of this
standard where kevin samuels was like do
you have a cookbook i'm like one
why why would i have a cookbook when i
have the internet like like i can't have
these old men telling telling me how to
cook when when i'm like okay one two
three